what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch from heavy spoilers
oh buddy Poe po that's how the Brits say it oh
we're gonna watch the episode five Easter egg
breakdown that he's got going for The Last of
Us episode Cinco Andrew Acres 7-Eleven showing
his arms today how are you I'm doing a lot
better than Jeffrey Pierce AKA Perry in the
last two uh episodes I have not run into
any bloaters lately so I'm good I'm good
are you a dad not yet not that I know of at
least well you got some jokes ready to go
good leave a like for Andrew's dad jokes today all
righty we're all feeling confident let's do this
so The Last of Us episode 5 is now out and in this
video we're gonna be recapping the plot breaking
down the Easter eggs and also talking about the
game's similarities and differences that's what I
wanted to hear survive endure and survive excuse
me as always this review won't contain spoilers
until the end of the video and that'll be for
people who've completed both pots now we hop right
after effects last week which saw the introduction
of salmon Henry with your eyes last time that
they'd follow Joe and Ellie and this is how they
randomly ended up on the same floor as they did
in the skyscraper this is confirmed in the episode
and Theory time right and the entry centers around
flashing out their backstory along with Kathleen's
on the podcast for the show the creators stated
that she's like Madame dufage from A Tale of Two
Cities and she says very Meek character who ends
up becoming a vengeful ringleader said on getting
revenge for the death of her family I will say as
much as I can have my back and forth about the
overall execution of that character I feel it's
really cool that they decided to cast an actress
who played against type and I really feel like she
gave it a roll yeah no I mean I I agree with you
I know she was by far your favorite character of
the series so far so yeah she was really fleshed
out but no I mean I I actually really appreciated
what they did with the character in regards to I
felt empathetic towards you know her motivation
for getting revenge on her brother even though he
didn't want that from her and I also did find you
know it interesting how you know she became that
in which she used to fight in regards to fedra and
now that's what she has become like the oppressor
I like that Lumen more than you but you know I I
totally get where you're coming from and Greg I
don't understand why you're not agreeing with me
because I'm a contrarian now last week we missed
that Tommy's voice actor Jeffrey PS was playing
the part of Perry that sounds good you didn't
miss that people it's in the chamber eagle-eyed
viewers but there were two bullets in there but
that he need to pull the trigger four times in
order to shoot Joel now in the game the pairs
origin wasn't as fleshed out as it is here in
that their accusing Hartford had been abandoned by
the military in fearing that it could cause danger
for Sam Henry let him out of there with some other
survivors they traveled into Pittsburgh searching
for supplies and this is when they were split
from the group by a bunch of writers they'd all
agreed to Rendezvous radar Tower which is when we
learn in the game that Sam was big and the events
played out much like what we get at the end of the
episode right there's several nuts see a journey
with Sam and Henry lace throughout the entry and
we sort of get a compressed version of it with
us having the office building Asian the sewers
the sniper section that you play through and the
infected that then swarmed the area Sam and Henry
were gray characters in the original game but
the episode very much elevates them showing that
they're willing to do dark things in order order
to survive there are of course a reflection of Joe
lennelly with them both sharing the same kinds of
Dynamics well again like one of the things that I
love so much about what they did with the actual
episode itself in terms of comparing to the game
was it did show a softer side so I think actually
making Sam Herring impaired automatically forces
Henry to become more protective in that way and
to be a little bit softer because he has to
communicate even at a better level I really
appreciated all the choices all around I think
that's a nice way to switch it up from what the
game does yeah for sure and obviously in the
game he's extremely protective of Sam but just
obviously albeit a lot more of a stricter way
so I I definitely enjoyed the contrast and the
difference that we got in the show too now it's
nice to have two different versions of it I just
love you know what Paul was saying too where they
just gave the character so much more depth rather
than you know they were from Hartford and then
that there you know they actually have a history
with the hunters that's what I love about again
biggest thing word we use when we talk about this
show I love the expansion that they've done on
so many different characters I I agree that time
now here we get the inner workings of how
they were part of Kathleen's team and we
learned that Henry sold out her older brother
to fedra this created an uprising in the group
overthrew Federer which meant that Henry and
Sam had a gun hiding in order to escape them
now we start off the episode with the
people celebrating the disintegration
of Federer shut up into the sky like a
firework and the people then shout freedom
again we have the We the People truck and in
case you missed our last video we pointed out
on that that it has roots in the Constitution
it's the first three words that appear in it
and it's very much the people believing that
they've what is the Constitution they're saying
we are the people appearing in that and Ellie's
opening scene that happens in the mirror either
way with all the uprisings come Bloodshed and the
celebrations are juxtaposed by the dead Federal
soldiers that now line the street those that are
still living are brutally murdered and the sigil
for them is presented with a fire beneath
hitting at the crumbling of this era I've
always been a bit hit and miss on the hate for
Federer as they did manage to stabilize America
by creating safe zones for the people episode
1 showed that though they kill the infected
without question they try to do it in a nice way
but as with all authorities there are those that
within that can be corrupted in evil this was
showcased in episode 3 in which we know that
they murdered some evacuees in case they became
infected in the game's counterpart Pittsburgh
you learn that the rebels did what they did here
and can piece enough things together to learn why
this was there's graffiti on federal buildings
complaining about how people are being starved
and when food ran low obviously they kept the
rations for themselves now the trucks are on the
streets looking for collaborators and over the
10 hours we can hear they'll offer Fair trials
this is clearly [__] lie though as we see
Kathleen ordering several collaborators to be
executed in the next scene there is something
about the show that I I do wonder if they are
driving the point home far enough because
the game really gives you a great insight
into why fedra is so messed up I'm curious to
know from like non-gamers if the show really
drives that point home as well because a lot
of this still feels like introduction to them
it still feels lived in but at the same time I
feel like there's some context that perhaps is
not being fully realized just yet on screen to
really understand this divide Rebels fedra and
all that stuff you know yeah for sure I mean I
definitely felt that a little more in the game
I do like the whole idea though when it came to
Kathleen's uh you know the militia group taken
over where they were having Fair trials remind me
a lot of The Dark Knight Rises when Bane took over
uh Gotham City and then they use the example of
A Tale of Two Cities which obviously a dark net
Rises is very heavily influenced on so I like
seeing the two parallels between the two that's
true good point I feel this is rapping on real
world politics and after the second world war
several Nazi collaborated bears were hunted
down throughout Henry's called a rat and Jill
refuses to work with him initially because
he doesn't want to associate with someone
who [__] over his own people to get a Lego
with fedra in the game he had a really tense
moment where they left you up squeak without
a paddle and I love how this uneasy Alliance
also carries over into the show we then see a
body being dragged behind a truck and this has
several knives in it this is complete Overkill
obviously I'm potentially dumb for a reason to
show all those that were involved in taking down
Federer it's a simple Caesar was killed he was
stabbed 23 times and this was done to show each
of the perpetrators had a hand in it and that
they were all in it together this episode very
much feels like the same sort of thing with the
rebels clearly showing that they're willing to get
their hands dirty in order to overthrow Pedra in
a changeup from the game we learned that Sam is
deaf unless he talks to Henry in sign language
and has a little magic board he can write on
this adds even more to just how vulnerable he
is and it clearly shows why Henry feels like he
has to protect his brother of course title text
is also done to mimic how it appears in the game
and the font they use is exactly the same as it is
one of them gives up Dr Edelstein who we learned
last week was killed by Kathleen or was it the
next week anyway lots of timing why me wibbly
wobbly stuff and she says that they'll be executed
if they don't give up Henry and Sam but even when
they do she still wants them wiped out this really
speaks to her character and how she refuses to let
her brother's death go unavenged her right hand
man Perry asks why the pair is such a priority
as a city still in a state of destabilization now
we learn from Henry that in fact it were driven
underground 15 years ago but they've clearly been
awakened Once More by the revolution happening on
the surface Kathleen doesn't care though and she's
willing to throw everything she has to make sure
the characters are caught as we learned last week
this involved overlooking a hole in the ground
teeming with infected and this short-sightedness
eventually leads to her downfall and the end of
her people throughout the videos you've talked
about how the shoners have constantly brought
up the theme of Love on the podcast and this
something that's definitely seen in Kathleen
definitely love can be good as in the case
of Bill and Frank but it also can have hugely
negative effects Kathleen loved her brother and
losing him is caused her to hunt down all those
involved in his demise at the expense of others
I love hearing that that's how the creators of
the series are talking about it because I've
never really put that word love into the context
of the games part one but especially part two the
consequences of what we do out of the act of love
but what's cool is that when you look at the game
you're like oh no that is exactly what that is
I've just never really used the word love in the
context of it all and the consequences of love
and I love the point how he drove it home where
you know how love was used in regards to Bill and
Frank and then you know with Melanie lynskey's
uh character Kathleen I was more thinking just
in terms of Revenge but obviously that Revenge
comes from her desire to avenge her brother out
of love again not going to spoilers for future
events I just love that it's just so Last of Us
in regards to you know the the Revenge story and
like what it does it consumes Us in the darkness
you know how it just embroils your entire mind and
and desires and all that that's what I appreciated
about the character and it just again just felt so
Last of Us now in overthrowing fedra she's pretty
much become the thing that she saw to replace and
there's a little line that hints towards this burn
the bodies it's faster this is of course what we
saw gel doing the Federal in episode one and it
showcases how they're both different wings of the
same bird it's possible that we actually saw the
collaborators bodies and if you cast your mind
back to episode 4 then you'll remember there was
a pile of them when Jill and Ellie drove through
the town this moment pulled from the game and in
that Ellie said that they weren't infected them
giving up the doctor is very on brand as well
because they've obviously been working with
Federer and are now betraying people in order to
survive another day and we see is Henry and Sam
end up meeting with the doctor who hides them
in an attic similar to how Anne Frank and her
family hit out during the Holocaust last week
Kathleen discovered it abandon with empty tins
of food and in this entry we see what happened
during the time that they were laying low we see
Sam drawing his character Super Sam and last
week we got a tease to this with him wearing
his orange face paint now I think one of the
running themes throughout the last of us is
how every character's childhood has been Stripped
Away because of the way the world is humans could
easily be here I did but everyone fights amongst
themselves and those children don't really get to
live come the end of this episode we now have
three different series and this comes in the
form of Sarah the child at the qz and of course
Sam Ellie and Nishi seems to be in enjoying this
world and though she's making the most of it she's
not really seen as a kid either described as being
cargo she's just someone who can help create
a vaccine and there she isn't really viewed
as a person you know what's funny about that line
cargo there's already enough similarities this in
the Mandalorian for Patriot Pascal yeah yeah but
he also refers to the baby Yoda it's Cargo in the
first season that's why they specifically Craig
Mason came up with that line he's like I wanna be
a game is it in the game well where he says she's
cargo yeah it could let us know in the comment
moments I don't it's not beautiful it's not coming
back I understand that but that I don't remember
that line from the game I'm not recalling that
line from the game but if it is let us know I'm
pretty confident he says it I'm pretty confident
he doesn't so we're at a crosshairs here you son
of a [__] all right we're gonna take the next
20 minutes to find this moment I've said this in
other breakdowns but children are our future and
having so many of them dying means there's no hope
for the human race wipe him out for 20 years but
when the kids start dying it won't be the infected
that get us it'll be the fact that there's no one
to carry on this species really poignant stuff and
we see 10 days going by with the pair hiding out
Sam had it so drilled into his head that Federal
of the enemy that evenness is reflected in the
artwork with the drawings looking like how the
soldiers do in the gaming show in another night to
the game we see Henry looking out the window and
off in the distance we can catch a yellow Bridge
from Pittsburgh in the source of material you and
the group had to make your way to assembly get
out of the Town eventually Joel and Ali ended
up having to jump off it and this happened
after they were chased by the Run truck ah
God I love this game
on the shore they were saved by Henry and Sam
who abandoned them when a ladder broke during
the chase with the truck at this point you then
pass through the sewers which we'll talk more
about in just a bit when we get to The Hideout
section now Sam is worried that the doctor isn't
coming and as we know he was captured by Kathleen
he told Henry to stay strong so that his brother
wouldn't worry but we can clearly see that this
is Weighing on him finally he decides to accept
the truth that he's not coming back and the pair
now to take their chances in the city also worth
noting that Sam has a yellow hoodie on at this
point and this is the same thing that he wore
in the original game that's the same hoodie is it
really they look so different to me oh the color
Green's a little lighter on the uh on the game
one but you think that's yellow I don't know Paul
is that the same color does that look
yellow to you I could be wrong if it is
it's a very very light yellow
what kind of British [__]
are you playing at today buddy but
you're dead but they're both jackets
he's the expert and you're supposed to be
better than us Henry gives him some orange
face paint which wasn't in the source material
and this is a nice little touch to add to his
character in the game you stop by a toy store
to hide out from the truck and Sam wanted to
take a robot Henry said no because it would
just take up space and again it showed that
kids couldn't be kids in this world Sam what are
you doing nothing get rid of it my backpack is
practically empty what's the world about taking
stuff it weighs like nothing rule what is it
we only take what we have to oh you took it in
the end and after making it to the radio tower
she did give it to Sam as a little present that's
why she died he turned the next day but she kept
this tone her backpack as a reminder of him Henry
ends up checking the street and this is when we
see the action scene from last week which gel
crashed his truck and had to shoot out with the
rebels I did go back and watch this scene again
to see if we could spot Henry but unfortunately
we we can't now we do at the moment where Joe
finishes the shooting lowers his gun and looks in
that direction that he doesn't actually see him oh
that's great oh man on this eventually love that
cartoon Man circle from last week and a nice bit
of attention to detail you can also see that Henry
has a giant flashlight on his backpack and this is
in line with the one that he also had in the game
now that's accurate Paul but it's on the wrong
side right there don't have to do this because
she unlocked the door he also goes straight at
the staircase and step on the glass that Joel
used to alert him however as we discovered in
episode 4 he's going deaf in one ear and this
is why he lay on one side every time he went to
sleep also with noting that in episode 1 he didn't
hear Tess entering tying back this whole deafness
thing going on with him wow what great card to do
any details man that's that's stuff that's so
easy to overlook it's good script supervision
or screenplay that is really impressive because
most movies and shows would completely Overlook
such a specific specificity specific a specific
thing I think you got it that one I nailed it but
I agree with you and I mean no yes I agree with
you I agree with you and I think again because
everyone knows I love to play the comparison game
but one of the other films that always just jumps
to mind when you know doing that kind of a scene
from a different perspective is Batman versus
Superman yes exactly that would be Superman and
Man of Steel so it just I got a lot of flashbacks
to that and again just really really good job
just showing us a different perspective while
still keeping the same kind of new because and
that's not easy to do so and I appreciated them
you know really taking their time and doing it
the right way you should watch the movie Vantage
Point I've never seen it well you're gonna see the
same story let us know 12 different times let us
know in the comments guys if you want me to watch
that on here are the gameplay sings differently
and after you chase by the Run truck You Have To
Shimmy along a walkway and this is when you jump
through a window by Henry he thinks you're right
at but upon seeing Ellie he realizes that you know
with them in camps where Federal were overthrown
they tend to either kill her outcasts the kids
because they just slow the others down where
are you from all the way from Hartford I think
Federer makes the best decisions I heard some
bad stuff going on down there yeah the military
Place probably looks like this by now this is a
major reason why Henry ended up leaving Hartford
as he knew Sam would probably be murdered by
the group that took over the military's Place
Jill almost beat Henry to death which is when
Sam stepped in with a gun drawn similar to what
we get here Henry likely realizes that they're
in a similar situation just an adult trying to
escort a kid through a hazardous City you know
what I've noticed one thing I wondered if the
show would do and they're not doing it you
carry a lot of [__] in the game you got a
backpack in the backpack you got all the health
kid you have the molotov cocktails you have the
bone arrows you got the rifles and you can only
carry up to a certain amount which is smart to
make it more realistic yeah but Pedro Pascal is
never carrying anything but like one gun you know
I wish she had a backpack a yellow backpack now
they end up sharing food and this obviously means
a lot in this new world survivors have to be even
more careful because food was how the cordyceps
spread and thus given the limited amount of food
that they have they have to be more tight with it
now we get a scene that sort of riffs on one from
the game in which they sit about Sylvania area
in the original Henry ended up taking Jill and
Ellie to their Hideout which was located in an
office block across the city and the game they of
course want to make levels and sections for you to
fight through whereas in a show they're not really
needed so you can just skip it and put the scenes
in the same location now you run into one of these
rooms and it had a similar sort of layout to what
we see in the show the game had Henry's Hideout
located just above the gate that was in front of
the entrance to the bridge and under the cover
of Nightfall you ended up launching your plan to
pass it yeah they do things differently and they
look over the city and point out the exits Henry
says he's never killed anyone and though this
is technically true we do learn that he caused
someone else's death although it's all serious
with Henry and Joel salmonelli at least have
some fun Pikachu are reading the pun bug to him
and get some similar moments in the show and game
all right ready ow the blueberry it's been
a while since that boy even cracked a smile
D in the game Henry and Sam were actually making
their way to the fireflies and Joel said it seems
like there's a lot of people putting their stock
on the fireflies these days yeah maybe there's
a reason for that you don't know where they are
you're just going to drag him across the country
to find him this was ironic as well because he he
was of course making his way across the country
Without Really knowing where they were either
anyway Henry draws up a map of the city and tells
them that they're going to be heading through the
maintenance tunnels Henry wants Jill to help him
navigate these as they could still have infected
in them Henry actually calls a click or a clicker
and you know what it's nice to see a live-action
thing not embarrassed by the terminology that they
use in the games he says that someone he knew from
federal that was the first time they said it the
possibility that some might be down there and he
and Sam won't be strong enough to deal with them
only he knows is though and the theory though is
that Kathleen won't follow them because of the
danger there could be now they head into another
building and this resembles the one that you first
move into when you storm the gate out well they're
here they head underground really going on we get
this line that's kind of a pessimistic which is
another two it's just you and your daughter we're
not related we're more like um I promise someone
I'd look after yeah yeah I can appreciate that
now as you mentioned earlier this is basically
combining the suic section of the game so that
it's part of Kansas as we stated Joe and Ali
jumped off the bridge and this is when they were
pulled ashore by Henry and Sam you found about
washed up along with some notes and a home in the
sewer that was once teeming with people children
were of course killed by the bandits unless they
fled here with their parents to try and carve
out a life I was gonna say that that's something
like this might have happened here but Joel says
that lots of people went underground on outbreak
day it's possible that people ended up lying low
here and then when the infected were pushed in the
ground they wiped them out because they'd bottle
themselves in yikes now the entrance to this oh
boy and this is something that also pops up in the
game when you first entered the sewers anyway when
they enter the room there are several things here
that are ripped right out of the source pictures
now against the back wall we can see a girl drawn
onto it and there was an optional cut scene in
which Ali played football against Sam yes I'm
saying football again I'm not saying soccer I've
had enough for you guys no you can probably hear
I'm very ill at the moment most of your audience
is us it's much appreciated and I hope it doesn't
ruin the video for you like it's ruined my life
making these videos for you I hate you so this
plays on the scene similar to what we get here
yeah it even sounds just
like the game uh calm down
I remember Sam asks Henry about the kick
and he's like all right keep it down buddy
did you see that I'm down buddy okay Davey you
were right about that line I missed closer to
Sarah because Sarah also played soccer when
she was a child hey said sucker for you guys
out there you suckers hey no we do get a little
subtle gesture by Joel here and he looks down at
his watch after looking at Ellie now that's
a great catch completely fluid that you can
catch that that flew over my head and I to be
honest because most you know because it was so
sad Hollywood [__] would do like a close-up on
Joel and really draw attention to it you know yeah
but that's just such a subtle way of capturing
the character Nuance yeah for sure and also we
got to see another moment of that right after Tess
had been bitten in the museum you know we see the
scene straight out of the game with the plank
yeah we saw after uh Joel and Ellie had had an
interaction he kind of looked at his watch which
you pointed out when that happened during our
reaction and I like to play the comparison game
too and soccer reminds me of bended Like Beckham
don't you mean football oh yeah no this reminds
me of the replacement starring Keanu Reeves love
that love love love that the director of Iron
Man this is Samia Sarah of course gave him and
looking at the watch reminds him of the daughter
he lost he also did this in episode 2 and as we
know it doesn't work so it's not like he's using
it to read what the time is it just shows how much
Ellie reminds him of Sarah and moments like this
say so much with so little there's a slide which
I think was in the game and also a big sign that
says house rules when you made your way through
the underground you could spot this and the rules
on both are identical why would I read any of that
[__] again doors are locked ask for password if
you don't know the visitor no shouting in noisy
play run to hiding spot when you hear the alarm
now in the game you accidentally set off one of
the alarms the infected they had bottles inside
a box on the end of a rope and setting this off
showed them where you were you also see blue
barrels with tubes popping at the top of them
and we learn in the game that these were used to
collect rain so that they had to supply water now
in what's my favorite Easter egg from the show so
far you see a child's drawing with Danny and ish
on the wall this is identical to how it appears in
the game also when traversing the suit let's see
the color palette is a little different on this I
mean the pic the picture yeah it looks completely
and but if yeah he actually has an extensive
backstory that you discover through notes that
you're spying throughout the sewers yeah which is
a great support in the game and he's based on the
character issue with Williams from the 1949 book
earthbite in that there was also a pandemic and
the character ended up establishing a community
of survivors like what we see here he was meant to
look like Ishmael from Moby Dick and this idea of
being a sailor carried across to the game wow did
you ever discover those letters I never I don't I
wonder if I did I just don't remember I I did and
I'm gonna be honest they were interesting but like
when I'm playing a video game and I have to read a
bunch of stuff even if it's interesting sometimes
I zone out I'm like I'm just gonna keep playing
there were times where I would read full-on
letters I didn't when it came to Danny Anisha
that whole thing in regards to sewer I didn't
go into the whole thing but I collected all the
notes but I didn't read it I'd get like a quarter
into it I'm like this is good but I want to play
right now I want to shoot I want to shoot some
some Infected right now I get you I mean that's
why I can't do less places when I play a game
sometimes I put it on pause to read a chapter
of a Stephen King novel ah gets in the way of the
momentum I mean if you're gonna pause it you got
to do a Stephen King novel so that I think you're
good after the outbreak he went to sea for several
months but eventually he had to go to show and he
landed near Pittsburgh this is the boat that you
encounter after the bridge and it's here that you
discover the first part of his story we learned
that he ended up going into the Suez and it's here
oh yes it's coming back ended up going into the
suburbs behind them which is where he came across
a family of other survivors though they initially
just traded supplies ish ended up inviting them
down into the sewers which is where they built
the community unfortunately someone didn't follow
the rules and they left the door unlocked which
is when the infected broke in by the time he got
there it was completely abandoned and we was a
horrifying event for those stuck inside one of the
notes said that the teachers barricaded themselves
in a nursery with some of the other children and
and had to well do what happened at the end of
the Mist you know that that's the only part I've
seen that I could say life's an ish and then you
die hey now ish actually made it and he and some
of the other survivors fled into the suburbs which
is the next area the characters go into in both
the show and game I was wondering if this old guy
was actually him but let's hope not now on top of
this we also see that very wild Starlight comic
these were collectibles in the game and they
told the story of Dr Daniela star who could
travel faster than light the cover here is pulled
directly from the PlayStation counterpod and this
is the aggression issue brought across from it in
the second game the comics and Beyond just being
comics and you also collected trading cards of
characters from the story this included Dr upman
Who was based on your druckman yeah aka the game
and series Creator Ali also says his catchphrase
Edge of the universe and back to
the edge of the universe and back
endure and survive excuse me endure and survive
and you know I really enjoy these moments with
them just getting to be kids as it's something
that we haven't really seen that much in the show
it's because you're a Dad we're not dads so we
don't give a [__] about their bonding am I right
buddy I didn't care at all I was not emotionally
invested in those two characters at all and in
fact when what happens to Sam happens I I didn't
give any two craps at all I was about to applaud
when it happened and then I had to restrain myself
because I thought people might misinterpret this
nah nobody misinterprets anything on the internet
no I really like that stuff too yeah it knows
it was good it was good and I seen the different
deliveries yeah yeah and two like like I mentioned
in in our uh reaction video uh me personally I
felt in the game he had a little bit of a crush
on Ellie in regards to he changed the his age
and and I like the dynamic in this a little bit
more personally just where again there being more
kids and he looks up to her like kind of an
older sister and I was definitely emotionally
invested in them for sure in the game but and it
was a little bit deeper and more fleshed out here
for me oh yeah no if it even adds a protective
quality for Ellie in that moment now when they
take the comic out the back we can also catch the
book to Old potatoes and me this sentence around
a girl whose parents are going through divorce
and she builds a relationship with her father
whilst the pair grow new potatoes from some old
ones initially the girl finds the potatoes in the
cupboard and she thinks they're gross but over the
book she learns and New Opportunities from then
they can grow something new and this is similar
to her parents divorce enabling her to have a
different but new type of life now this is very
much reflected in jail who are making something
new in this world that's falling apart around
them now it's at this point they decide to wait
a couple of hours and then they decide to make
their move this causes a bit of time difference
from The Source material as you were riding the
suburbs and played at the sniper section during
the middle of the day yeah though it happens at
night and this is because you don't really travel
through the sewers now Joel and Henry took it
out and he apologized however Henry reveals what
really happened with Kathleen's brother the way he
describes him he sounds like the second coming of
Mr Beast and I bet he's the kind of person who
would always like comment and subscribe even
if the host's voice didn't sound as good as it
normally does anyway Henry says that Sam got sick
with leukemia and thus he had to work with Federer
to get a special drug that was in short supply
little did Henry know this pushed the resistance
over the edge and we ended up getting what we see
in Kansas City Henry gave up someone amazing that
could have led the people into a new world for the
life of someone he loved and we'll talk later
on about how this thematically repeats through
the show and that's super spoiler section just I
wonder where that's going to go Jill was a father
and similar him he'd of course do anything to
protect the ones he loves protect credit Kathleen
and we see her in the room that she grew up in
with her brother this is a donut ornaments and
also kids playing football again tying back this
photo of Sarah check the Analytics our biggest
audience is America who are planes who are playing
soccer now Perry returns with some bad news chill
and Henry are still at large son of them in the
city Kathleen reveals that her brother's name was
Michael and it's possible that he was a firefly
due to a dog tag that we find with that name on in
the game might be a reach here but Michael likely
did there was a different way of life and this is
of course something that the fireflies also do the
idea of him giving people optimism is represented
in Kathleen who tells a story about how they used
to change their rooms using their imagination
he was so beautiful it was constant gunfire
screaming and bombing in the town but in this
room they managed to make it feel like a safe
place Michael likely did that to everyone growing
up and it really makes you question whether Sam's
life was worth his obviously you don't want to be
killing kids but the Carnage it's caused by
handing him over shows that even things done
with the best intentions have their own costs as
Michael character sounds like quite a compelling
fella what would you think about us getting a
spin-off seeing who Michael is just doing good
deeds letting people use their imagination who's
the guy who wrote Peter Pan the one that Johnny
Depp played uh Finding Neverland you mean I
mean yeah he played him in Finding Neverland
no he played JM Berry didn't play Peter Pan he
played I said who's the guy who wrote Peter Pan
Jamberry yeah oh my God Andrew you're ruining
our back and forth uh so I had a great thing
going here and then you ruined it why did I even
pause it you said who's the guy who played Peter
Pan I said who's the guy who wrote Peter Pan he
said Play I said Johnny Depp played him I don't
know now who's the guy who wrote Peter Pan the
one that Johnny Depp played uh Finding Neverland
you mean but where were you going with this I
forgot it stays in the video now Kathleen said
she visited her brother in jail and he told her to
forgive last week when talking to the doctor she
said that the room they were in could be the one
Michael was tortured at and again because of this
she can't forgive now we jump backwards sounds
like John the Baptist them making their way into
a bank car park this could be riffing on a secret
location in the second game in which he traveled
West like bank and got a shot Canali I like the
game once you hit the Main Street you peppered
by a sniper they have the layout exactly the same
with them at the end of the road similar to what
happens here Joe uses cars for cover and he makes
his way down to it before you take out the Gunner
Henry running up in the game the pair make a break
for it here but they're almost shot when trying to
escape I really do wish in the show they made it
harder for him to get to the sniper I really feel
like I do I do agree with that point I love the
episode but I do agree with that point for sure I
think even if I didn't play the game I would have
been like oh what a cool setup for a really tense
I I love that kind of action scene really sniper
up there and you gotta like find your way around
to get to the sniper it did feel kind of easy
the the way he got around and just got up there
whereas in again not going into like if you were
in a game or if you were but in the game it was
a lot more difficult yeah there were other guys
charging at you as well but just if you like got
a little around a corner that sniper was gonna
hit you like it was hard and it's a sniper so
it makes fun and he's an old ass sniper too so
you know he's good he's gotta he's got 200 years
of experience that's my first the game also had
riders in houses along the street whereas this
guy is just by himself he's much older than his
game counterpart and it explains why Joel's able
to get the drop on him so easily you're the cgo
looking out to a river with a bridge on it which
is riffing on the one from the Pittsburgh
chapter that you had to get to I was also
wondering whether Joel was thinking should I make
a break for it um I don't think he is but yeah let
me know below if you had that interpretation now
in the game tonight I always wondered why this
guy didn't move when he saw you coming up the
street his position is clearly given away but
here we see that he's been working with Kathleen
and thus he didn't really want to vacate this spot
he was deliberately trying to hold them in place
so goodbye Kathleen in her group time to arrive
and they then show up at this point this whole
scene riffs on the game quite a lot and in it
Jill takes a sniper and he watches the Run truck
arrives in the show we see the battering ram on
the front being used to clear out cars and this is
something Joel touched upon last week when talking
about how the roads were cleared must have been
some truck yeah they used to stick big ass clouds
on them and clear the roads for their tanks
and such a rebel popping at the top that was
throwing molotovs this caused him to drop it in
the car which said it alight and this then crashed
into one of the houses I do gotta give Andrew
credit he did say foreshadowing on that moment
in the reaction for episode four but I cut it out
because I was like is someone gonna give us a lot
of crap for spoiling it even though I don't think
it's that big of a deal it's a super shot every
contact I appreciate you saving me the trouble of
being accused of spoiling so Craig thank you so
much and for the recognition you're you're the
best friend anyone could ever ask for I know
right back at me
you're doing good thanks bro now the infected
sprung out and this is how Sam got bit you ended
up playing to the towers in fact you can even see
his limping there you never know pretty much how
the sequence ended here they changed things
up where the truck driver still crashing but
to make things even more tense we get Kathleen
holding everyone except y'all at gunpoint she
says [__] them kids and justifies murdering them
by saying kid style all the time she sees Sam as
being someone who should have been left to his
fate instead of costing her her brother leftover
bait still has a hand to play Zen unleashing a
terrifying horde of infected we see one set on
fire and this is a similar effect to what would
happen when he hit one with a molotov in the game
because Joel couldn't get hit you're kind of
just sniping away and having a bit of a laugh
now at this point we see a big bad blowout who
is first teased at all the way back in episode
two so there aren't super infected they just build
fungus spores on you [__] I hope not you could
also hear the creature growling into the cracks
in the floor last week and this makes a really big
entrance in the game he actually faced off against
them during build section but I'm kind of glad we
got the greatest love story ever told instead and
they kept his arrival for this scene I would have
preferred it if right before when Frank's like
take me to the bedroom yeah and then as he's
Wheeling him in then a bloater just burst through
and just tears them apart I mean it definitely
would have been subversion of expectations
so if you would have seen a comment yeah from
that perspective it would have added you know a
different flavor to the episode you know we'll
never know now I think they really missed a great
opportunity there yeah they did they definitely
did but uh no I I I love the what they did here
with the uh the bloater like actually seeing it
on the big screen I just I I love what they did
with this and then showing the power level too
and just again the difference of what you saw from
the game in here in the game I mean you definitely
get a horde coming out at you but this is like
on a different less scale that we've never ever
seen and to see it in live action the way it was
meticulously shot and how they were all coming out
it just it was really freaking scary and awesome
at the same time so like the fire illumination for
the night it's great that's true it's like hell
has risen yeah in the game it was a one-hit kill
if they grabbed you stick their fingers in your
mouth and rip your head apart Perry gets killed
in the exact same way and seeing this happen in
the background I was like that they went there
child clickers don't appear in the game and I'm
guessing that this was used because it later
kills Kathleen and she was very much saying how
kids didn't really matter uh yes that completely
flew over my head I didn't even put that two and
two together oh the I ironic I was more caught up
in ah you know Catherine if you just let them
go you might have survived there is an ironic
sense of death there not only that but you were
also thinking too like I can't stand Kathleen so
you were just so mired yeah the simplest iconic uh
line of foreshadowing just went over your head and
I was just so mired by your hate that I missed it
so this is all my fault I do I blame you for most
things even when you're not around it's true guys
he does but usually it is my fault so I actually
take it if John's not around it's gonna be you or
God she's got to look for something Henry and Sam
are pinned down like what happens in the original
work but Ellie saves them and they make a run for
it she uses a knife and this is also a tactic
that she bust out in the source material as we
said Kathleen gets killed and in an eerie final
shot we see the infected running towards the city
they'll likely destroy the resistance as they
lie asleep in their beds and I doubt that even
Dorothy would want to get back to Kansas eh now
in the game Henry said Pittsburgh it's skeleton
Crews at night which is why they opted to move
out then and I can imagine it being a similar
thing set up in Kansas this means it's gonna be a
very short-lived Revolution and because Kathleen
couldn't forgive it's led to this downfall now
the group make it to a motel and we see Henry is
really shaken up by it but the kids have got to it
okay anyway the conversation in the game is a lot
more light-hearted I do love how the adults seem
a lot more shaken up and the kids are like yeah
we're good for our Comics just another day because
they're used to growing up in lifestyle where
this is still something that's that interrupted
their life yeah for sure and also obviously the
difference here with Henry in regards to the
game in this I mean in the game he had killed
a lot more people and we also we witnessed him
killing people when we're trying to escape out of
Pittsburgh obviously the description we get of him
in the show is the only person that he's killed
technically was by way of proxy I mean did we it
could be wrong did we witness Sam Actually killing
during that battle or was it mostly just running
away and Joel was saving them I know Henry got a
few kills in but there was so much chaos happening
it's hard for me to remember but obviously we saw
that Ellie got a few kills so she's used
kind of used to doing it but to me it just
it captured the whole moment of like I've never
experienced something like this and just like
getting that shock of your first kill so that's
how I interpreted it and that's where I thought
this actor did a phenomenal job of like showing
that Terror of like getting through something so
crazy and and the adrenaline rush that comes
with you know killing for the first time
there is an adrenaline rush when
you do it oh yeah no you've told
me you've told me many times I know I can't stop
don't look in Greg's backyard guys you can
come by it's better than keeping it inside
it starts to smell anyway the conversation in
the game is a lot more light-hearted with them
talking about Tommy before moving on to the
group not showing up it's Tommy's birthday
that's all he wanted to do Harley Davidson yeah
I went to Harleys and drive cross country oh man
I could die happy if I could
just ride one around the block
what was it like it was good it was real good
good keep can you believe this guy detail come
on man give me details describe it you know what
you two deserve a little privacy Ellie this isn't
just any regular motorcycle okay you get on that
bad boy you feel that engine nothing like it oh
yeah how would you know seen it in my dreams okay
I don't think anyone from my group is gonna
show up in the show gel invites Henry and
Sam to join them on their quest to find
Tommy and this will give them a new Fresh
Start the game also changes things slightly
and with Sam he was clearly wrestling with
what would happen now that he'd been bit is
everything all right everything's fine well
the good night how's it that you're never scared
who says that I'm not
what are you scared of
scorpions are pretty creepy
scorpions
um being by myself
scared of ending up alone
what about you
those things out there
what if the people are still inside
what if they're trapped in there
without any control of their body
and all that I'm scared of that happening to me
okay first of all we're Team now okay
we're gonna help each other out and second
they might still look like people but that
person is not in there anymore I'm in the
show Ali and Sam said about reading comics
and he eventually asks if she's ever scared
we gotta scene that riffs on the game with the
answers being written down and shed between the
two whereas in that it was a conversation like
the previous cutscene Ali says she's scared of
being alone and this plays into a character
moment that we'll talk about in the spoilers
section Sam also asks if it's still you inside
when you turn and he then shows her his bite
this is unlike the game is in that he keeps it
to himself however he does pull up his trouser
lag to reveal it like what we get here Alicia
was just how naive she is because she believes
her blood can kirim and it very much plays in her
believing that she is the vaccine she sort of has
a Maasai complex and believes she can heal the
sick but this of course doesn't end up working
out it's very much a kind of I don't know kids
view of Science and he gives Ali another cruel
dose of reality in the harsh light of day in the
game Henry gelinelli sleep in the same room and
when she went to get him up she discovered he'd
been turned we see Sam's back first like what
we get here but Ellie spent the entire night
with him bow the scenes play out in a similar
way and I'll drop them side by side so you can
see the differences as well as what they kept
that smells good it does good morning
where's Sam I let him sleep in for once
oh well if you wanted to join us you can
go wake his ass up the one time you lose
Sam I interrupt this side by side to say that
is some interesting parenting to let your two
teenagers sleep in the same room alone
very true I mean now be it one was eight
and fourteen but yeah that's a good point I
mean you gotta post-apocalyptic world or not
you gotta have a little better parenting
skills there should be some boundaries
all right see boundaries the little
things great damn what the hell
[__] he's turning
that's my [__] brother
screw it
come on
[__] you're right oh my God see oh no Sam Henry
hello stay here Henry
I'm gonna get that gun from you
okay oh okay okay easy is it sure
this is nobody's fault Henry it's not
gonna [__] Henry Henry no oh my God
let me know
they both end in Sam and Henry's death and that
closes out another entry with some big characters
passing away I think every episode I probably
didn't have music in the live action big death
in it and the first had Sarah Tess was in the
second Bill and Frank in three and now Henry and
Sam yeah it actually hurts more than it did in the
game because we know that Henry gave up Michael in
order to save his brother he still had to kill him
though once he became infected and it shows how
dark and Bleak this world actually is even if you
save someone this can still be taken away from you
and this all can happen at a moment's notice
outside they bury the yellow car smacked you
there me outside they bury their bodies and now he
creates a makeshift gravestone using Sam's Board
in the game you actually came across a child's
grave and it's just as depressing as it is here
should be smaller I forgot to leave that
stupid robot on his grave what should I
do with it I mean what I want to talk about it no
why not how many times do we need to go over this
things happen and we move on it's just that's
enough all right I'm sorry Ellie of course
forgot to put the robot toy on it but here she
remembers to drop Sam's Board she writes I'm sorry
and clearly deals with the survivor's Guild of
the situation Ellie is still alive from her bite
whereas Sam isn't and her actions the night before
potentially also cost Henry's life to pass it out
and in the moment that riffs on their Silhouettes
and the credits we close out with them journeying
out west now for the next part of the video
we're gonna be talking about game spoilers and
things that will be let's go story for you if you
haven't played them what the [__] is wrong with
you why the [__] haven't you played the last
of us we're five episodes Stephen you started
anyway the two characters that I think reflect
Joel here are Kathleen and Henry who both end up
doing bad things out of love Kathleen's love ends
up turning her into a bitter and vengeful person
and in the end this Dooms her entire town this
could be similar how Joel was affected by Sarah
and his attack at the end Dooms Humanity because
we don't get a vaccine I know people kind of go
back and forth over whether the vaccine would have
worked or not but the second game done is kind of
spell out that there was a pretty big chance now
how is Henry like Joel well Henry's actions to
save Sam ended up leading to Michael's death he
put the life of the person he loved bubble else
and this could be reflected in Joel's actions to
kill the fireflies at the end that's more of a
well they're both pretty tenuous but I thought
I'd just bring it up here in case they end up
going that route in the series I'm pretty sure
they will at this point because so far it's been
almost identical to the game but the bill and
Frank episode and the odd change here and there
it's also possible that Kathleen is somewhat of a
mirror of Abby as both are avenging someone that
was murdered at which eventually leads to losing
a lot definitely saying she's scared of adding up
alone could possibly play into the next episode
which will potentially take them to Jackson so I
feel like they've been planting these seeds for
the last of us too we are talking full spoilers
here I feel like they've been planting these
thematic seeds that are very much mirroring so
much of the last of us too to prepare us for the
inevitable when they beat Joel's head in yeah via
a new protagonist in the name of Abby and I'm
gonna eat it up oh you're talking about where
she gets a Joel in one right yeah I love it Andrew
yeah I can't wait for Pedro to get his head back
yes I just want to see a reaction from grogu when
he's uh when he sees that you know that's the oh
yeah for them to cut it together in regards to
spoilers we talked off camera about this after
episode five when you know obviously that Ellie
has the Messiah complex and she tries to do the
blood transfusion in regards to sandwich I love
that change like I really deeply appreciate I
actually like that a little bit better than the
game personally obviously we don't know what a
person goes through in their mind when the turn
happens but just knowing that someone knew about
it and he wasn't like alone in the moment I just
it felt a lot deeper and more personal to him from
that perspective and that Ellie did try to save
him whereas in the game he really went by himself
alone like he like he felt like he had nobody in
regards to when he was turning by himself also
we talked about off camera that when she tries
to give him the the blood transfusion we talked
about the importance of Dr Jerry Anderson Abby's
uh Abby's father and like Okay so this character
obviously as described in the second game is
so important because you can't just use Ellie's
blood like you need someone who knows what
to do with the blood in order to create this
vaccines I like how again you're talking about
laying down seeds so like yeah this just showed
the importance of Abby's father when you can't
just use Ellie's blood to just save someone like
you need a doctor who knows what they're doing
they're laying the foundation for Abby's father so
you keep saying we talk off camera but sometimes
sometimes sometimes we'll do the board like that
Sam had and we'll just communicate with each other
but sometimes we do talk off camera you know but
Greg has to give me permission he said did I tell
you you could talk no you're not talking to me
I've got a big channel here my name's Craig Alba
you're just nobody I've instructed my assistant to
make sure you communicate to her via email I think
I lost that email I'm gonna need to get it again
that explains why things have gone to [__]
around here yeah I haven't seen the trailers yet
as we make these videos before they release but
I'm guessing that the next entry centers around
them relying with Tommy in the game jail pretty
much wanted to fleece Ellie off to him and she
ended up running away for a bit chilling Tommy
headed out to get her which is when they came
across right as but eventually they managed
to catch back up to her which prom promised
to take care of the fireflies himself and I
can't imagine that basically being the plot
of the next entry now as for my thoughts on this
one I did think it was a solid way to build up
last week and even though I knew it was coming
the Henry and Sam deaths were still devastating
just leaves that feeling of hopelessness that
the last of us is built upon and you can see
how the characters become completely jaded and
self-centered no one's really gonna look after
them so they have to look after themselves unless
they push themselves into this one track mind
based solely on Surviving this is what Joel had
but Alias made him realize that there's more to
life than just making it through the day-to-day
bill of course discover this and it's very much
layered throughout the entire season I think Henry
and Sam was spot on as well as you couldn't really
ask for more accurate adaptations of them yeah
I know Sam wasn't deaf but he played the part of
a kid trying to be a kid in the apocalypse really
well and it did provide a devastating ending that
I think a lot of people are going to be shocked
by I actually found myself almost being like Joe
at this point and as the guys just put Tessa's
death at the back of his mind and kept going and
that's what I do once they ended up dead these
characters they have big passings and I'm I'm
like well just gotta keep surviving I guess can't
stand around it really shows how well crafted that
the series is but I do have some faults with it I
kind of felt like Melanie lynskey was a bit weak
thank you I don't know why anyone would really
follow her I get the whole brother dying put
her in charge but she didn't really come across
someone that could command others just a nitpick
for the episode and yeah if you disagree that's
fine I disagree let me know below now I hope you
enjoyed the breakdown either way and obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on it so make
sure you comment below well yeah man good [__]
learning a lot that's probably my favorite one
you've done so far out of the breakdowns here man
I think you did a good job I will not message you
that personally but I will say it here on camera
to look like a better human being and also too
I do want to add to one thing you did mention in
regards to Jesus sorry I know we haven't talked in
a lot in this video but I did like the the point
that you made whereas in the video game I made a
point okay let's hear it that's here where Henry
when he shoots himself uh we hear the the game
music by Gustavo santalaya in the background
which was I still thought that music was great
but not having the music in the background in
the show it just you feel the gravity and the
weight of the situation a little bit more it's
a little more gut-wrenching without this or the
even though the score was fantastic in the game
it's a little more gut-wrenching for me just not
because again you feel the weight of the situation
and how daunting of what he had to go through to
save his brother and then having to do that like
I didn't even think about that in the moment like
oh there's no background score where there was
in the game so thank you for pointing that out
Lance door Lance would be the perfect
person to survive an apocalypse with one
you know what I'm just gonna I always
had this whole thing about you being
a firefighter because he's a firefighter
and that would be like a great person to
surviving definitely but here's the other thing
you gotta you got you got yourself a a wife and
a kid in Valentine's Day is coming up so uh
I'm gonna redirect the shout out to be like
well there's going to be a fire it's going to be
put out this coming Tuesday at the Canadian border
where you're from I should have gone with the
apocalypse one I think I had more to do with that
I definitely could have Rift more on that then on
uh you doing fun stuff with your with your wife
smoking hot wife my God
yeah she's a looker that one
yeah you're lucky son of a [__]
I hate you but Lance I'm really happy
you're part of our patreon page dude